sigamos resolviendo problemas en el
último vídeo estábamos calculando la
probabilidad de que en siete
lanzamientos en siete volados de una
moneda justa no salga ninguna anguila y
pues para calcular eso observamos que si
no sale águila tiene que salir sol
porque la moneda solo tiene dos caras
entonces la probabilidad de que en siete
lanzamientos no salga ninguna águila es
igual a multiplicar un medio siete veces
porque son siete lanzamientos y en cada
lanzamiento
independientemente de lo que haya salido
en los otros lanzamientos la
probabilidad de que no salga sol es un
medio y un medio elevado a las siete que
es un medio por un medio por un medio
siete veces es igual a uno entre 128 y
resulta que hay 128 posibles resultados
a la hora de lanzar la moneda siete
veces y además cada uno de esos
resultados tiene una probabilidad de 1
entre 128 ahora por qué digo eso pues
acerca de la cantidad de resultados que
hay podemos pensar que tenemos y un
lanzamiento dos lanzamientos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete y en cada una de estas
líneas vamos a poner así no salió a
hitler o s si no salió sol y el chiste
es que en el primer lanzamiento tenemos
dos opciones y sin importar cuál de las
opciones nos salió en el primer
lanzamiento en el segundo lanzamiento
también nos puede salir águila o nos
puede salir sol o sea que hay dos
opciones para el segundo lanzamiento y
lo mismo pasa en el tercer o cuarto
quinto sexto y séptimo sin embargo si
nos fijamos en el resultado final o sea
por ejemplo cuando vemos que nos salió
primero un águila luego un sol un sol
una águila águila
el sol
este es un posible resultado de lanzar
la moneda siete veces como vemos que en
cada lanzamiento tenemos dos opciones
entonces el número de combinaciones que
se pueden hacer con estas letras en
siete lugares que vamos a estudiar eso
más de fondo en otros vídeos es 2 por 2
por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 por 2 qué
entonces hay 128 combinaciones de
águilas y soles en siete lugares bueno
espero no haberte confundido con esto
vamos a borrarlo y calcular algunas
probabilidades
calculemos por ejemplo cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener primero un
águila águila águila águila estoy así 17
lanzamientos entonces águila águila y al
final en el último volado en el último
lanzamiento obtener un sol
ok pues resulta que en el primer
lanzamiento obtener un águila tiene una
probabilidad de un medio después en el
segundo lanzamiento sin importar que me
salió en el primer lanzamiento la
probabilidad de obtener un águila es un
medio lo mismo en el tercer lanzamiento
sin importar que me salió en el primero
o segundo lanzamiento la probabilidad de
obtener un águila también es un medio y
así un medio un medio un medio y lo
mismo la probabilidad de obtener un sol
en el último lanzamiento sin importar
que obtuvimos en todos los demás
lanzamientos también es un medio que
entonces la probabilidad de obtener este
resultado en particular donde no se le
haya la águila a águila águila águila
águila y al final un sol
es de un medio por un medio por un medio
por un medio por un medio por un medio
por un medio que es igual a un medio a
la 7 que es igual a 1 entre 128 algo que
es muy importante aquí es que como
estamos lanzando una moneda justa
monedas
usted
que creo que en el primer vídeo de esta
serie le estábamos llamando moneda legal
y el hecho de tener una moneda justa
hace que la probabilidad de obtener
aguilar sea igual a la probabilidad de
obtener sol en cada volado y por lo
tanto estas probabilidades tienen que
ser igual a un medio entonces cada uno
de los resultados que podemos obtener
aquí son x probables o sea porque aquí
si en lugar de buscar la probabilidad de
obtener este resultado
cambiemos si queremos encontrar la
probabilidad de obtener un resultado muy
parecido pero que en el tercer volado en
lugar de obtener un águila obtengamos un
sol lo único que tendríamos que hacer es
cambiar esta probabilidad de un medio
por la probabilidad de obtener un sol
que también es un medio entonces a la
hora de sacar la probabilidad de obtener
este resultado nos va a quedar otra vez
128 así es que todos los resultados son
algo que le llamamos x probables
aquí pero
bables qué significa que todos los
posibles resultados de nuestro
experimento recuerdan que el experimento
es lanzar siete veces la moneda tienen
exactamente la misma probabilidad otra
cosa es que nosotros calculamos la
probabilidad de cada resultado aquí está
la probabilidad y vimos que como
teníamos una moneda ajuste entonces los
resultados eran x probables ahora lo que
muchas veces hacemos cuando estamos
haciendo probabilidad es darnos cuenta
que todos los resultados son x probables
y entonces contar la cantidad de
posibles resultados
resultados y ya que sabemos cuántos
resultados podemos obtener cómo sabemos
que son equiparables entonces sabemos
que cada uno de esos resultados tiene
una probabilidad de 1 entre
el número de posibles resultados
y nosotros lo hicimos al revés nosotros
lo hicimos al revés pero esta es la
forma más común de proceder y porque es
cierto esto pues porque si tenemos n
posibles resultados todos tienen la
misma probabilidad y como la
probabilidad total de obtener alguno de
esos resultados siempre es igual a 1
entonces cada uno de estos resultados
tienen que tener una probabilidad de 1
entre el número de posibles resultados
en fin vamos a calcular más
probabilidades entonces déjame borrar
todo esto ahora cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener
exactamente
acta
mente un águila
cinco tiros cinco
lados
pues bueno si estamos buscando que haya
exactamente un águila en cinco volados
el resto de los volados tienen que ser
sol cierto a ver entonces por ejemplo
esto podría ser sol sol sol sol aguilé o
también podría pasar sol sol sol el sol
incluso sol sol allí la sol sol creo que
ya sabes cuál es el patrón verdad sol
águila sol sol sol o águila sol sol sol
sol todos son todos los posibles
resultados que satisfacen esta condición
de aquino de que salga exactamente una a
esto de exactamente es muy importante o
sea si nosotros nos estuviéramos
preguntando acerca de que salga al menos
una entonces esto sería mucho más
complicado estos no serían todos los
resultados que satisfacen esta hipótesis
tendríamos que considerar por ejemplo
el águila águila sol sol y un montón de
otras cosas también tendríamos que
considerar allí la allí la allí la allí
la águila no pero bueno estamos hablando
de exactamente una águila en cinco
volados así es que estos cinco
resultados son todos los resultados que
satisfacen esta condición y bueno vamos
a empezar por calcular cuál es la
probabilidad de cada uno de estos
resultados pues a ver aquí para que
saliera este sol hay una probabilidad de
un medio aquí hay otra probabilidad de
un medio en el segundo lanzamiento que
salga sol en el tercer lanzamiento
también un medio un medio y un medio
entonces la probabilidad de este
resultado de obtener sol sol sol sol
allí es igual a un medio
a las 5 que es igual a 1 entre 32 y de
la misma forma calculamos estas
probabilidades y todas son iguales a 1
entre 32
he hecho cualquier sucesión de cinco
lanzamientos tiene esta misma
probabilidad cierto porque sacaron un
águila o sacan un sol los dos tienen una
probabilidad de un medio y en general
cuando lanzamos una moneda cinco veces
hay 32 32 posibles resultados y cada uno
de estos es nada más uno en particular
de esos 32 resultados y resulta que
cinco uno dos tres cuatro cinco de esos
32 resultados cumplen con esta
característica de que salga exactamente
un águila en cinco volados entonces lo
que hacemos para calcular esta
probabilidad como cada uno de los 32
resultados son nec y probables entonces
lo que hacemos es contar cuántos
resultados cumplen con esta propiedad
que en este caso son 5
5 y lo dividimos entre el número total
de resultados que es 32 y así es como se
calculan estas probabilidades
cuando todos los resultados posibles del
experimento son x probables ahora si te
fijas
esto también es igual a la suma de las
probabilidades de todos los resultados
que cumplen con esta propiedad aunque ya
tenemos aquí en nuestros resultados que
cumplen con esta propiedad tenemos aquí
la probabilidad de cada uno de estos
resultados y si la sumamos todas lo que
nos queda es 5 entre 32 bueno estas son
dos formas de calcular esta probabilidad
donde éste utiliza muy fuertemente que
cada uno de los resultados de tirar
cinco veces la misma moneda tiene
exactamente la misma probabilidad en
este mismo vídeo vamos a ver un ejemplo
donde no todos los resultados tienen la
misma probabilidad pero bueno eso es
para después por el momento ahora vamos
a preguntarnos cuál es la probabilidad
de no obtener
no tiene
exactamente
un águila
ahora está probabilidad puede parecer
muchísimo más difícil de calcular y en
realidad si es muchísimo más difícil de
calcular si no aplicamos un truco por
ahí que estoy a punto de enseñarte
porque ahora hay muchísimos resultados
muchísimas secuencias de siete
lanzamientos de soles y águilas que
satisfacen esta condición o sea por
ejemplo estos dos resultados que
habíamos puesto por aquí si satisfacen
eso de que no estamos obteniendo
exactamente un águila o sea porque aquí
obtuvimos dos águilas así es que no
obtuvimos exactamente un águila igual
aquí aquí obtuvimos cinco águilas y lo
mismo pasa si ponemos por ejemplo cinco
soles
o permutamos estas dos águilas después
vamos a ver mucho acerca de las
permutaciones
esencialmente es que cambiamos del lugar
los resultados por ejemplo ponemos por
aquí una de las as y ponemos por acá la
otra ahí ponemos aquí los soles
esta es una permutación que también
satisface esta característica de no
tener exactamente un águila el chiste es
que no sería nada sencillo escribir
todos los resultados de los cinco
lanzamientos que satisfacen con esta
característica sin embargo podemos usar
un truco muy útil en probabilidad a ver
vamos a empezar por borrar esto tenemos
que la característica de no obtener
exactamente un águila es lo opuesto de
obtener exactamente un águila aquí me
faltó escribirlo pero esto de no obtener
exactamente un águila es
5 o la 2 muy importante pero bueno el
chiste es que cualquiera de los 32
resultados que podemos obtener al tirar
5 volados o cumple con esta
característica o cumple con esta otra
característica cierto o sea o tiene
exactamente un águila o no tiene
exactamente un águila y entonces la
cantidad de resultados que satisfacen
esta característica
es igual a el número de resultados que
hay que es 32 menos el número de
resultados que cumplen con esta
característica que vimos que eran 5
cierto entonces esta es la cantidad de
resultados que cumple con esta
característica y habíamos visto que como
tenemos una moneda ajuste si tiramos 5
volados cada uno de los posibles
resultados tiene exactamente la misma
probabilidad de 1 entre 32 así es que la
probabilidad de no obtener exactamente
un águila es igual al número de
resultados que cumplen con esta
característica
entre el número total de resultados que
es 32 aunque hay 32 menos 5 es igual a
32avos
aunque ya calculamos esta probabilidad
ahora el truco que usan todos ya sin
pasar por todos estos detalles es decir
que esta probabilidad es igual a 1 menos
la probabilidad de obtener
exactamente
realmente un águila en cinco
lados
siempre que tengas dos características
opuestas la probabilidad de uno es igual
a uno que es igual a la probabilidad de
obtener cualquier resultado menos la
probabilidad de obtener algún resultado
que cumpla con la característica opuesta
ok de hecho esto lo podemos ver como 32
entre 32 menos 5 entre 32 y aquí se ven
32 entre 32 es igual a 15 32avos es esta
probabilidad que es la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado que cumpla con la
característica opuesta
bueno vamos a ver más ejemplos y ahora
vamos a ver un ejemplo donde no todos
los resultados tienen la misma
probabilidad de ocurrir que podríamos
hablar acerca de monedas cargadas donde
sea más probable que salga águila que
salga sol pero pues sería bueno también
cambiar de ambiente no entonces porque
no trabajamos con los porcentajes de
anotaciones con tiros libres y digamos
esto es puramente hipotético me
encantaría que fuera así pero
definitivamente no es así que yo tengo
un porcentaje de tiros libres anotados
de
80% y nos vamos a meter mucho más en
esto cuando veamos cosas de estadística
pero básicamente lo que dice es que de
las últimas 100 veces que tire un tiro
libre anoté aproximadamente 80 de ellos
aunque tal vez no son las últimas 100
veces que tire sino las últimas 1000
veces y que de esas últimas mil veces
que tiene un tiro libre anotó 800 y
bueno podría decirse que la estadística
y la probabilidad son dos caras de una
misma moneda el chiste es que nosotros
usamos este tipo de información que
estudia muy a fondo la estadística para
aproximar la probabilidad de que el note
en el próximo tiro libre que tire ok
podríamos pensar que como el note el 80%
de los últimos mil tiros libres que hice
podríamos pensar que hay una de 80% de
que anoté el próximo tiro libre aunque
digamos que estamos aquí y que voy a
tirar un tiro libre y por lo tanto
existe la posibilidad de que anoté en
ese tiro libre o de que no anoté en ese
tiro libre ahora esto de aquí nos dice
que una buena forma de aproximar la
probabilidad de que anote en el próximo
tiro libre es punto 8 que es el 80% de 1
y entonces la probabilidad de que no él
no te tiene que ser punto 2 porque la
suma de las probabilidades de todos los
posibles resultados tiene que ser igual
a 1 muchas veces
estas cantidades que es la probabilidad
con la que algo sucede le llamamos
y entonces esta probabilidad de aquí
tiene que ser 1 - p ahora la pregunta
que queremos hacer ahorita cuál es la
probabilidad de anotar
tres veces seguidas
veces
vidas
esta pregunta es muy parecida en la que
estábamos haciendo acerca de los
lanzamientos pero la diferencia aquí es
que anotar y no anotar no tienen la
misma probabilidad ok entonces no todos
los resultados tienen la misma
probabilidad a ver en este árbol de
probabilidades para anotar tres veces
seguidas pues estamos aquí queremos
anotar una vez después podemos anotar
a notar anotamos con probabilidad punto
8 que además si anotamos o no la segunda
vez en teoría no tiene nada que ver con
qué resultado obtuvimos en el primer
lanzamiento y ahora para obtener
nuestras tres anotaciones seguidas
necesitamos anotar otra vez punto ocho y
bueno aquí no escribir todos los árboles
porque se vuelve más complicado
porque son muchas opciones pero bueno te
los puedes imaginar el chiste es que
anotar tres veces seguidas tiene una
probabilidad de punto ocho por
punto
8.8 por
8.8 vamos a usar la calculadora
ayer punto 8 por punto 8 por punto 8 es
igual a punto 51 2 es igual a punto 51 2
así es que si lo sacamos en forma de
porcentaje esto es igual a 50 y 1.2 por
ciento pero bueno el chiste es que si
suelo anotar aproximadamente el 80 por
ciento de los tiros libres que tiro
entonces la probabilidad de que anote
tres veces seguidas es mayor a un medio
por muy poquito o sea nada más por 12
milésimas pero de todas formas es más
probable que note tres veces seguidas a
que no anoté tres veces seguidas
ahora algo muy interesante de este
ejemplo donde anotamos con probabilidad
punto 8 y no anotamos con probabilidad
punto 2 y nos fijamos en por ejemplo dos
lanzamientos
vientos
y luego nos fijamos en todos los
posibles resultados de esos dos
lanzamientos por ejemplo podremos anotar
primero y después volver a anotar o
primero notar y luego no anotar o no
anotar y después si anotar o nunca
anotar cierto estos son todos los
posibles lanzamientos podemos calcular
sus probabilidades por ejemplo aquí
anotar tienen la probabilidad de punto
ocho y anotar la segunda vez también
tiene una probabilidad de punto ocho
entonces tiene una probabilidad de punto
64 ahora sacamos la probabilidad de
primeros y anotar y después no anotar
que entonces anotamos primero con
probabilidad punto 8 y no anotamos
después con probabilidad punto 2
entonces 2 por 8 16 aquí no anotara
tienen probabilidad punto 2 si ya no
está tiene probabilidad punto 8 así es
que no anotar y después de anotar tienen
probabilidad punto
y finalmente no anotar y no anotar tiene
una probabilidad de punto 2.2 es punto
04 si te fijas en dos lanzamientos
tenemos cuatro posibles resultados sin
embargo estos posibles resultados no son
x probables entonces ahora la
probabilidad de obtener exactamente
exactamente una vez a osea anotar
exactamente una vez ya no la podemos
escribir como el número de resultados
que cumplen con esta característica que
en este caso nada más son estos dos
resultados o sea estos dos resultados
entre el número total de resultados
esto es igual a un medio no la
probabilidad en estos casos se tiene que
hacer sumando las probabilidades de cada
uno de los resultados que cumplen con
esta característica ok esto si es igual
a la probabilidad de este resultado que
es punto 16 más la probabilidad de este
otro resultado que es punto
16.32 que si se fijan no es igual a un
medio y esto sucede porque la
probabilidad de anotar que es punto 8 no
es igual a la probabilidad de no anotar
que es punto 2 en fin en el próximo
vídeo vamos a calcular más cosas con
esto de las anotaciones y el basketball
y capaz que hasta empezamos a aprender
acerca de probabilidad condicional pero
bueno te veo en el próximo vídeo